Tag ist das in der Landeshauptstadt
Hannover und ein Wahltag für rund sechs
Millionen Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
Niedersachsen die das schöne Wetter zu
einem Ausflug nutzen an den Maschsee
vielleicht aber auch an die Wahlurne
darum geht's der Landtag in Hannover
wird neu gewählt und damit entscheidet
sich auch wer Niedersachsen künftig
regiert
guten Abend aus dem niedersächsischen
Landtag und hier aus unserem zentralen
Wahlstudio in der Hannover Messe
begrüßen wir Sie zu diesem Wahlabend ein
gutes Jahr nach der Bundestagswahl und
mitten in einer Zeit von Krieg und Krise
gibt dieser Wahlgang heute auch ein
Stück weit Auskunft über die politische
Stimmung im Land jedenfalls hier im
Flächenland Niedersachsen Matthias ja so
sieht's aus wo SPD und CDU noch relativ
stark sind und in einer groko regieren
die die Bezeichnung groß noch verdient
auch wenn beide wohl etwas verlieren
könnte die fortgesetzt werden aber das
will so recht niemand es ist die letzte
große Koalition auf Landesebene aber
auch sie gilt als Notlösung und
Auslaufmodell Rot-Grün könnte die
Alternative sein denn die Grünen werden
wohl deutlich zulegen gibt es überhaupt
eine Machtperspektive für die CDU im
Moment schwer zu erkennen kommt die FDP
überhaupt wieder in den Landtag von
Hannover das könnte knapp werden die
Linke erneut nicht und wie viel Protest
sammelt die AFD ein viele spannende
Fragen für diesen Wahlabend Bettina ja
ist es 18 Uhr haben wir schon ein
bisschen mehr Klarheit dann pünktlich
die Prognose der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen
und in der Zeit bis dahin schauen wir
uns wie immer die Ausgangslage hier im
Land genauer an die war angesichts der
derzeitigen Krisenlage durchaus
untypisch was die Themenlage in diesem
Landtagswahlkampf angehen Matthias
Kubitza zeigt uns das
auch in Niedersachsen heißt es diesen
Herbst und Winter warm anziehen und
hoffen dass die düsteren Zeiten ohne
schlimme Schäden vorüberziehen
den Menschen zwischen Nordsee und
Weserbergland wird nachgesagt sie seien
Sturm erprobt sie haben schon viele
Krisen und Pleiten überstanden doch die
Konsequenzen des ukrainekriegs drücken
die Stimmung und stellen fast alles
andere in den Schatten die Bundespolitik
die steht jetzt im Vordergrund oder
international Politik so dass ich mich
mit der hiesigen
Politik wenig auseinandersetzt und doch
bewegen die Niedersachsen auch die ganz
typischen landesthemen extremer
Lehrermangel also wenn man sich anschaut
wir haben jetzt Leute die haben
befristete Arbeitsverträge die werden zu
den Ferien entlassen und sollen nach den
Ferien wiederkommen geht schon los mit
dem Krippenplatz und mit dem
Kindergartenplatz also wende dich nicht
quasi schon bewirbst wenn das Kind quasi
noch nicht mal geboren ist hast du keine
Chance auch hier in Niedersachsen nicht
alles eine Frage des Geldes die
Energiekrise abfedern hat jetzt
Priorität denn die Menschen fragen sich
worauf verzichten was und noch drin
ich versuche auch irgendwie ein bisschen
Energie zu sparen aber dass ich friere
das sehe ich auch nicht so ganz ein aber
meine Heizung ist doch gar nicht an aber
ich habe auch das Glück dass die unter
mir heizen also
ich muss richtig massiv sparen damit ich
halt die Wohnung richtig gut bezahlen
kann doch auf jeden Sturm folgt
irgendwann auch wieder Sonnenschein
sicher auch in Niedersachsen
ja Peter Kunz ist unser Studioleiter
hier in Niedersachsen und hält heute
Abend die Stellung im und im Moment noch
vor dem Landtag von Hannover Peter ja
klassische Themen wie Schule und Bildung
wir haben es gerade gehört die sonst bei
Landtagswahlen eine viel größere Rolle
spielen sind hier so ein bisschen in den
Hintergrund gerückt wie hast du den
Wahlkampf erlebt ja Bettina die
Temperatur hat sozusagen ständig
zugenommen die große Koalition aus SPD
und CDU hat ja gesagt sie hätten
harmonisch miteinander regiert also gab
es gar nicht so viel Themenfelder auf
denen man sich wirklich beharrten konnte
aber
Energiepreise Sicherheit also das was
uns in Deutschland alle bewegt das hat
hier übernommen und die CDU schießt
scharf auf die Ampel und das Ergebnis
von FDP Grünen und SPD heute Abend wird
dann auch ein Signal nach Berlin sein
über die Jahrzehnte Peter gab es hier
Niedersachsen immer ein Duell zwischen
SPD und CDU um den Platz an der Spitze
des Landes nun hält seit fast 10 Jahren
Stefan weil das Ministerpräsidentenamt
für die SPD und die Niedersachsen sind
seiner jedenfalls sagen dass die
vorumfragen noch nicht überdrüssig ja
das sagen die Wahlforscher
offensichtlich ist er eben jemand der
hier passt nach Niedersachsen also
selbst viele CDU Wähler können sich
ihnen weiter als Landesvater vorstellen
er ist jemand der nicht durch
Extravaganzen auffällt ist ein kluger
Verwalter manche sagen auch ein
trockenes Brötchen das wird dem glaube
ich nicht ganz gerecht aber ist sicher
ein norddeutscher ein klassischer und
damit fasst das Gegenmodell eines Markus
Söder beispielsweise ja danke Peter für
den Moment wer verliert wer gewinnt das
ist die Frage heute Abend und unsere
Reporterinnen und Reporter werden das
wie immer wie sie das kennen bei unseren
wahlsendungen bei allen Parteien in den
wegnehmen zu den Gewinnern könnte die
AFD gehören vor fünf Jahren erstmals
eingezogen in den Landtag von Hannover
mit gut sechs Prozent Moll in ihlau die
vorumfragen sagen der AFD ja Gewinne
voraus
ja wird Tina 12 Prozent plus X das hat
sich die AFD hier in Niedersachsen
vorgenommen mit dem Spitzenkandidaten
Stefan matsischewski trotzdem hatte die
AFD ein recht schwierigen Wahlkampf die
Fraktion im Landtag hatte sich vor zwei
Jahren aufgelöst und der Landesverband
der gilt als zerstritten und dann kommen
noch zwei weitere Punkte seit Juni ist
die AFD unter Beobachtung des
Verfassungsschutzes und die
Staatsanwaltschaft Hannover
ermittelt gegen den landesvize
Landesvorsitzenden der AFD also bleibt
abzuwarten ob das der Partei
letztendlich Stimmen kosten wird genau
wir werden es in gut zehn Minuten schon
etwas genauer wissen Dankeschön Mollin
und wir gehen zur FDP die beim letzten
Mal noch vor der AFD landete jetzt
müssen die Liberalen hoffen dass sie
überhaupt im Landtag bleiben Britta
Jäger bei der FDP das ist eine richtige
wackelpartie an der Fünf-Prozent-Hürde
wie ist die Stimmung
und eigentlich auch gesehen ja der Saal
hat sich jetzt hier schon mittlerweile
gut gefüllt im Brauhaus Ernst August
hier ein paar hundert Meter vom Landtag
entfernt und die ersten sitzen hier auch
schon beim Bierchen aber man muss sagen
beim frustbierchen wohl Stefan Birkner
der FDP schwitzenkandidat hatte zu
Beginn der wahlkampfperiode schon mal
ausgerufen dass die FDP zweistellig
werden soll aber hier wissen eigentlich
alle dass das jetzt ein utopisches Ziel
ist genauso wie möglicherweise auch die
7,5% aus 2017 und hier
man sich an der Basis wie man was man an
der Basis hört machen viele die Ampel in
Berlin verantwortlich dafür denn dort
soll die FDP einfach Dinge mittragen die
dem eigenen Klientel eigentlich nicht zu
vermitteln sind also die FDP stellt sich
hier auf eine lange Zitterpartie ein und
möglicherweise auch auf eine sehr
schwere Aufarbeitung in den nächsten
Tagen
ja das Abschneiden der FDP könnte sich
tatsächlich in Berlin auswirken auf das
Innere Verhältnis in der Ampel Regierung
das gilt natürlich auch dann für die
Grünen und wie sie hier abschneiden die
mit einem deutlichen Plus rechnen können
heute Abend jedenfalls sagten dass die
Formfragen und wieder mitregieren wollen
Oliver deuka wie groß ist jetzt die
Zuversicht
ja die zuversichtlich schon ziemlich
groß der Saal wo die Grünen feiern rund
2500 Meter entfernt vom Landtag das ist
der Saal in dem der damalige oder der
amtierende Ministerpräsident Stefan weil
seinen großen Sieg eingefahren hat und
hier feierte vielleicht auch ein kleines
oben erstmal dafür ja man geht so um die
16 Prozent davon aus dass sagen die
Umfragen auf jeden Fall für die Grünen
das ist ein gutes Ergebnis dieser das
Beste was Sie überhaupt in Niedersachsen
eingefahren haben wobei vor zwei Monaten
rund die Umfang da waren sie noch
stärker aber wenn es denn 16% pi mal
Daumen wären dann wäre es doppelt so
viel wie das was sie 2017 eingefangen
haben und naja man kann sich aussuchen
sie sind Königsmacher mit wem man
regieren will mit der SPD vielleicht
auch mit der CDU naja und weil man das
weiß kann man auf Forderungen stellen da
geht es um Inhalte die man vielleicht
gut durchdrücken kann wenn man mit der
mitregiert und sicherlich auch posten
ja Dankeschön Oliver für diese Eindrücke
wie immer am Wahlabend dabei ist
Professor Karl Rudolf Korte der den Arm
mit uns begleitet guten Abend ja guten
Abend und er hält ja für die
ampelparteien in Berlin durchaus was
bereit gerade weil es hier eben auch um
bundesweite Themen gegen nicht nur um
landesspezifische Themen inwieweit ist
das aus ihrer Sicht hier heute ein Test
auch für die Berliner Ampel großer Test
ein Zwischenzeugnis aber noch viel mehr
in Referendum geradezu über das
Krisenmanagement der Bundesregierung
diese Art des experimentellen Regierens
in Energiefragen in kriegsfragen es gibt
ja keinen Plan dafür dominiert am Ende
Zuversicht Mut oder Angst das werden wir
heute sehen ob das machen belohnt wird
oder er das kümmern der Abstand für
expedieren der Spitze ist in den
vorumfragen jedenfalls ziemlich
komfortabel Stefan weil kann sein
Landesvater Bonus hier in die Waagschale
werfen Landtagswahlen sind ja oft ganz
starke persönlichkeitswahlen also er
wäre dann hier der Typ Kümmerer ja auf
jeden Fall aber das reicht nicht man
muss auch Macher sein sonst wird man
auch damit abgestraft wie ein kennen das
Muster aus vielen zuletzten zuletzt
gesehenen Landtagswahl dass der
Amtsinhaber belohnt wird mit dem Bonus
als krisenlotse erpersonalisiert alles
er fokussiert alles auf sich und
insofern nur wer große Fehler macht wird
am Ende abgewählt
vielen Dank für den Moment wir vertiefen
das natürlich später ja wie ist die
Stimmung hier im Land was sind
Erwartungen und Hoffnungen der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger das lautet heute
Abend wieder unser wählerreporter
Karsten Behrendt aus der heute am
Wahltag in Hannover unterwegs war wir
hören mal rein
die Herbstsonne die strahlt hier schon
den ganzen Tag auf die Palmenblätter am
nördlichen Ufer des Maschsees es sind
sehr sehr viele Menschen hier unterwegs
und mit einigen haben wir uns
unterhalten und sie gefragt ob sie an
diesem Wahlsonntag eher ein
Wechselstimmung sind oder ob sie sich
wünschen dass es so ähnlich weitergeht
wie bisher
schon in Wechselstimmung das Sachen
besser werden dass das Leben vielleicht
einfacher wird im Moment wird es ja
schwieriger und teurer also da wünscht
man sich schon Verbesserung ja ich
glaube ja dass das richtige brot-grün
läuft und ich hoffe mal dass die blaue
Parteien nicht allzu viel Stimmen kriegt
ich wünsche mir die Grünen dass sie mehr
Einfluss gewinnen dass sie noch mehr
machen
mehr Umweltschutz idealerweise FDP
natürlich am liebsten den
Ministerpräsidenten das wird nicht
passieren und insofern denke ich muss
man sagen ja CDU und FDP im Prinzip darf
man ja nur sagen FDP und CDU AFD darf
man ja nicht sagen die haben auch mit
Sicherheit gewisse Dinge die ganz ganz
fürchter sich sind aber ja also SPD und
Grüne aus meiner Sicht nicht
Stimmen aus der Landeshauptstadt
Hannover viele sind gespannt wie dieser
Wahlsonntag ausgeht wer gewinnt und wer
baden geht und damit zurück zu Bettina
Schausten ins ZDF Wahlstudio ja
Dankeschön Carsten Behrendt aber AFD
darf man ja sagen so ist es ja nicht und
wir werden natürlich mit ein paar Tagen
hier heute Abend die Ergebnisse auch
besprechen und diskutieren und schauen
jetzt genauer darauf was die
Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten ihren
Wählern anbieten natürlich geht es vor
allem um das Rennen an der Spitze dazu
noch mal Matthias Kubitza
der Lack ist ab beim rot-schwarzen
Zweckbündnis die große Koalition von
Stefan weil und Bernd Althusmann bekommt
wohl keinen zweiten Anstrich mehr weil
will Ministerpräsident bleiben aber mit
den Grünen weiter regieren die Wähler
halten ihren Landesvater für kompetent
seine SPD vor der CDU aber im Swing
state Niedersachsen das weiß weil muss
man bis zum Schluss kämpfen
ich mache mir gar keine Illusionen
Niedersachsen Wahlen sind typischerweise
immer knapp und ich rechne auch diesmal
mit einem knappen Rennen im Moment
erlebe ich allerdings doch eine Menge
Zuspruch im Schatten des Amtsinhabers
Wirtschaftsminister Althusmann der CDU
mein wahlkämpft gegen den eigenen Chef
bleibt aber deutlich blasser
es wird ein Koffer und kopfrennen geben
in anderen Bundesländern hat es sich am
Ende auch herausgestellt dass die CDU
dann doch stärkste Kraft wurde mit
Abstand von daher bin ich fest davon
überzeugt dass wir alle Chancen haben
die Grünen deutlich stärker als vor fünf
Jahren mit Lust aufs regieren
wir lagen bei der Bundestagswahl letztes
Jahr bei rund 16 Prozent und ich würde
mich sehr freuen wenn wir das dieses mal
toppen können die FDP schwächelt schafft
es womöglich nicht in den Landtag
wir treten an um der nächsten
Landesregierung anzugehören das ist
unser Ziel wir wollen unsere
modernisierungsagenda umsetzen die AFD
diesmal wohl zweistellig
ja es gibt eine Alternative blau ist die
Farbe der Hoffnung und der Zukunft des
Aufbruchs Umfragen und der Wille der
Parteien deuten darauf hin dass sich
Niedersachsen für die nächsten Jahre
einen rot-grünen Anstrich geben könnte
gut aber dazu muss es natürlich erstmal
überhaupt reichen in vier Minuten die
Prognose Stefan weil gegen Bernd
Althusmann das war das Duell schon vor
fünf Jahren und jetzt wieder die
Formfragen Matthias geben uns ja
Hinweise wer das Rennen machen könnte
naja es war Bettina ein sehr stark
personalisierter Wahlkampf ohne echte
Wechselstimmung fürs Amt des
Ministerpräsidenten das sehen wir hier
in der Grafik Stefan weil soll
Ministerpräsident bleiben das Sagen 55
Prozent seinen Herausforderer von der
CDU Bert als Husmann wünschen sich nur
26% der Abstand zwischen den beiden ist
sogar noch etwas größer als vor fünf
Jahren und sogar jeder fünfte
CDU-Anhänger wünscht sich das weil im
Amt bleibt und welche Koalition wünschen
sich die Niedersachsen die bestehende
große Koalition finden 33 Prozent gut
aber 42 Prozent schlecht Rot-Grün wird
von allen Möglichkeiten noch am besten
bewertet 42 Prozent finden das gut eben
viele schlecht Schwarz-Grün und Jamaika
da sehen wir die langen roten Balken das
wird sehr klar abgelehnt von allen
Möglichkeiten politisch sind beide
Möglichkeiten die wir hier gerade
gesehen haben ohnehin eher
unwahrscheinlich Dankeschön Mathias wir
schauen auf die Stimmung und Erwartungen
bei Titelverteidiger und Herausforderer
und beginnen jetzt bei der CDU da das
Carsten Rüger ja Carsten am Ende hat als
Husmann versucht sich mit Attacken gegen
die Berliner Ampel von der SPD
abzusetzen gibt es denn Hoffnung doch
noch Nummer eins zu werden
hier in der Fraktion der CDU Plakate der
ganzen Kandidaten die noch in den
Wahlkreisen sind und einer der eben auch
bis zur letzten Sekunde Wahlkampf
gemacht hat während Althusmann der
Spitzenkandidat er war auf 50
Marktplätzen ist in Altersheim gegangen
hat Hände geschütte um so ein bisschen
das Image des steifen blonden kühlen
abzuschütteln aber ein CDU Mitglied
sagte mir es kommt auch was ganz anderes
an wenn rot grün rein rechnerisch
möglich ist sagte er dann haben wir
nichts mehr mitzureden dann brauchen wir
mit gar keinen mehr reden dann sind wir
draußen dann können wir nichts machen
man weiß weil würde gerne die grüne
nehmen die Grünen für sie ist Althusmann
und die CDU das ist so ein rotes Tuch
geworden weil Altus man das AKW Emsland
verlängern die Laufzeit verlängern will
also es ist äußerst spannend hier und
einer sagt das ist wie Weihnachten wir
wissen nur nicht ob wir was geschenkt
bekommen
danke Karsten bei der SPD ist Christina
von Ungarn Starnberg Christina Stefan
weil hat das Ziel genannt in der Tat
zurück zu rot grün und die Zuversicht
dass das klappt war ja durch die
Formfragen in der Tat begründet wie sie
gesichert sind jetzt die
Sozialdemokraten er Bettina die
Erwartungen sind groß das sieht man an
den Häppchen die hier schon angerichtet
sind und an den Kaltgetränken der Druck
allerdings auch und das sieht man an den
Herren hinter mir vor allem er hier Gerd
Schröder war eine Belastung im Wahlkampf
für Stefan weil der die Vorwürfe an sich
abperlen lassen musste von der Gerd
Schröder Moskau connection betroffen zu
sein Sturm ist erst wenn die Schafe
keine Locken mehr haben das hat er
gestern gesagt auf der
Abschlusskundgebung und insofern ist man
hier bereit zu regieren egal wie
stürmisch die Zeiten sind
ja danke schön Christina von
ungarn-sternberg die den Abend weiter
bei den Sozialdemokraten verbringen wird
und während wir hier noch gemeinsam über
das Bild mit den Locken nachdenken
schauen wir natürlich mit großer
Spannung auf die Uhr wir haben jetzt
noch gut zehn Sekunden bis zur Prognose
der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen also wird
die SPD tatsächlich die Nase vorn haben
mit wem kann sie dann weiter regieren
wie schneidet die FDP ab kommt sie in
den Landtag und wir haben jetzt die
Prognose für die SPD im Land
Niedersachsen 32,5 Prozent das sind
Verluste CDU
27,5 ebenfalls Verluste grüne 14,5
deutliche Gewinne FDP 5 mit Verlusten
und nicht sicher ob es reicht für den
Landtag die AFD 12 Prozent deutliche
Gewinne linke 3% mit
sie wird nicht im Landtag vertreten sein
und für die anderen zusammen 5,5 so das
ist eine ein klarer Wahlsieg für die SPD
ein recht großer Abstand zur CDU Stefan
weil hat hier das Rennen gemacht und
jetzt wollen wir natürlich sehen wie ist
die Sitzverteilung und für welche
möglichen Koalitionen reicht es Matthias
genau das schauen wir uns jetzt an die
Sitzverteilung nach diesen Zahlen im
Landtag von Hannover der hat mindestens
135 sitze da kommen aber noch überhangs-
und Ausgleichsmandate im Laufe des
Abends hinzu wir gehen jetzt von dieser
Zahl mal aus und demnach kommt die SPD
auf 48 Sitze die CDU auf 41 die Grünen
auf 21 die FDP auf 7 und die AFD auf 18
Sitze sie sehen in diesem in dieser
Torte das gelbe Kuchenstück wir schauen
uns eine zweite Grafik an in der dieses
Stück fehlt dann nämlich wenn die FDP an
der 5%-Hürde scheitern sollte was dann
dazu führt dass die anderen Parteien den
ein oder anderen Sitz mehr bekämpft das
wissen wir zur Stunde noch nicht wir
schauen auf die möglichen Koalitionen
wenn die FDP im Landtag ist dann 68
Sitze braucht man für die Mehrheit
reicht es trotzdem dicke für SPD und CDU
für eine Fortsetzung der großen
Koalition für Rot-Grün aber es ist dann
schon ziemlich knapp nur ein Sitz mehr
als man mindestens braucht Schwarz-Grün
wird es deutlich nicht reichen und für
Jamaika wo ihr gemerkt wenn die FDP im
Landtag ist gilt das nur ebenfalls würde
es sehr knapp reichen wenn die FDP aber
nicht im Landtag ist dann hat nach wie
vor SP CDU große Koalition eine große
Mehrheit SPD und Grüne eine etwas
deutlichere und CDU und Grüne das dann
die spannende Frage ob Schwarz-Grün
rechnerisch eine Mehrheit hätte zur Zeit
nicht
ja das ist die Unsicherheit des heutigen
Abends und das wird wahrscheinlich auch
noch etwas bleiben die spannende Frage
wird eben sein ist die FDP drin oder
nicht aber man muss feststellen auch
wenn sie im Landtag vertreten wäre würde
es knapp für Rot Grün reichen und jetzt
gehen wir natürlich zum Wahlsieger des
heutigen Abends zur SPD Kristina wie
wurde das prognoseergebnis aufgenommen
wohl war groß als die Zahlen hier gerade
kam wir haben Boris Pistorius in der
ersten Reihe gesehen den bisherigen
Innenminister hier war man sehr froh
über diese Zahlen auch wenn sie
natürlich unter denen der letzten Wahl
gelegen haben
hier also bereit für Rot-Grün Stefan
weil hat gesagt er möchte auch die volle
Amtszeit durchmachen er hat gesagt i'm
the normal one das ist eigentlich ein
Zitat von Jürgen Klopp aber das
verwendet Stefan weil gerne weil es ihm
selbst charakterisiert offenbar hat er
damit gepunktet und damit will er weiter
punkten übrigens wird heute nicht weiter
gefeiert hier bei der Fraktion sondern
man wechselte einen Club der heißt
Capitol da hat die SPD schon mal
gefeiert das war 1998 damals hatte man
47,9 Prozent damals hieß der
Ministerpräsident Gerd Schröder und der
wurde danach Kanzler
ja Dankeschön Christina 32,5 Prozent das
sind Verluste von gut vier
Prozentpunkten aber es ist eben auch ein
Vorsprung von 5% Punkten auf die CDU das
war hier also kein Kopf an kopfrennen
Stefan weil hat dieses Rennen klar
gemacht und jetzt gehen wir zu CDU wir
wollen natürlich auch dort sehen wie
dieses prognoseergebnis aufgenommen
wurde und rufen Carsten Rüger
es ist nicht verwunderlich man hätte
eigentlich eine Stecknadel hier fallen
hören können so leise ist es hier
gewesen nur ein leichtes Raunen als
diese Zahlen hier auf sichtbar wurden
und damit sichtbar wurde dass man doch
momentan so wie es aussieht als
Verlierer da steht wenn nämlich Rot-Grün
eben möglich ist dann weiß man dass man
einfach außen vor ist und das gab einige
die eben am Nachmittag gesagt haben ach
wir sind ganz optimistisch wir sind
zuversichtlich wir werden stärkste Kraft
dann können wir wenigstens Gespräche
führen dann können wir auch an die
Grünen vielleicht ran treten auch wenn
sie vielleicht gar nicht mit uns wollen
vielleicht ist dann auch eine große
Koalition eine Fortsetzung möglich aber
so wie es jetzt aussieht weiß man dass
man eigentlich aus dem Spiel raus ist
und deshalb auch diese Ruhe und Stille
hier Betroffenheit ja Dankeschön Karsten
Rüger für diese ersten Eindrücke gut
sechs Prozent
Verlust zum letzten Ergebnis in
Niedersachsen und klar eben nur auf Rang
2 das ist ein guter Abend für die CDU
wir haben jetzt schon eine erste
bundesstimme ich bin in Berlin verbunden
mit dem CDU-Generalsekretär Mario Czaja
und hoffe er kann mich hören schönen
guten Abend ja
schlechteste Ergebnis seit vielen
Jahrzehnten in Niedersachsen unter 30
Prozent lag die CDU hier zuletzt im
Jahre
1955 was ist da passiert und schief
gegangen
ja zunächst lassen Sie mich gratulieren
an die SPD und an Herrn weil der diese
Wahl gewonnen hat es ist für uns kein
schönes Ergebnis wir hätten uns wir
hätten uns gewünscht dass wir diese
Wahlen besser abschneiden dass wir das
Vertrauen gewinnen es ist nicht gelungen
wir danken den Wählerinnen und Wählern
in Niedersachsen wir danken natürlich
beim Althusmann dass das so wunderbar
ein Wahlkampf geführt haben aber wir
haben leider dieses Ergebnis nicht
erreichen können was wir wollten wir
wissen jetzt hatte ich gefragt woran es
liegen könnte die CDU ist ja angetreten
um die Regierung in Niedersachsen zu
übernehmen liegt jetzt so deutlich
hinter der SPD und der der wurde sogar
mehr Wirtschaftskompetenz zugetraut
warum hatte Althusmann warum hatte die
CDU kein Mittel gegen die SPD
der SPD ist es gelungen sich von dem
Bundestrend völlig abzugrenzen man hat
nicht die Fehler aus Nordrhein-Westfalen
wiederholt dass man mit dem
Bundeskanzler plakatiert hat
weil hat einen eigenen Wahlkampf für das
Land geführt und deswegen ist es uns
nicht gelungen auf die besonderen Fehler
die eben auch gerade hier in Berlin
vollzogen werden
hinzuweisen es war ein Niedersachsen
Wahlkampf und insofern ist das leider
ein nichts schönes Ergebnis für uns wir
müssen jetzt schauen was dabei für
Möglichkeiten sich ergeben ob wir in
Koalitionsverhandlungen gehen können
auch wenn die Federführung natürlich bei
der SPD liegt aber wir würden uns ein
stabiler Regierung für Niedersachsen
wünschen wir brauchen gerade in diesem
Zeiten von steigenden Preisen in der
Zeit in der die Frage der
Energieversorgung so eine wichtige Rolle
spielt eine stabiler Regierung es wäre
gut glaube ich wenn man eine stabile
Regierung fortsetzen könnte da höre ich
jetzt schon das Werben für die
Fortsetzung der großen Koalition raus
wegen aber noch mal fragen wenn das so
ist wie sie schildern dann war doch
diese schlussattacke die ja auch ihr
Bundesvorsitzender Friedrich Merz unter
hat in Hannover gänzlich falsch damit
jedenfalls konnte nichts mehr
ausgerichtet werden gegen weil in
Niedersachsen
ja wie gesagt im Ministerpräsidenten
weil ist es gelungen sich von der
Bundes-SPD und von dem schlechten Ruf
des Bundeskanzlers Olaf Scholz
abzugrenzen er hat keine gemeinsamen
Plakate mehr mit ihm gemacht er hat sich
klar zum Ausdruck gebracht dass es um
Niedersachsen geht und insofern ist das
passiert was häufig eben auch passiert
der Ministerpräsident hat ein Amtsbonus
und daraus heraus sich dann auch im
letzten ran dass derjenige Kandidat dann
gewinnt der vorher den
Ministerpräsidenten stellte
der CDU-Generalsekretär schönen Gruß
nach Berlin und dankeschön
so wir schauen jetzt auf die Grünen das
sind knapp sechs Prozentpunkte Gewinn
zum letzten Mal allerdings hatte man
eigentlich noch ein bisschen mehr
erwartet wir schauen jetzt mal zu den
Grünen wie ist denn da das
prognoseergebnis aufgenommen worden
na ja die Stimmung ist hier natürlich
riesig hier wird viel diskutiert und als
dann tatsächlich dass die Prognose über
den Bildschirm hier lief da war ein
Riesengeschrei ein riesen Jubel von
freut sich ganz besonders ja man hätte
sie vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr
gewünscht als das was da kam aber man
hat sich letztendlich fast die Prozente
verdoppelt und ich habe eben gerade ganz
kurz ein paar Leute gesprochen ganz klar
für Sie jetzt das ist natürlich der
Regierungsauftrag zusammen
wahrscheinlich mit der SPD also man ist
ja super glücklich man freut sich das
beste Ergebnis was die Grünen bisher in
Niedersachsen einfahren konnten und
damit wieder zurück zu dir Bettina ja
14,5 in der Prognose bei mir ist der
Bundesvorsitzende mit Nuri pur schönen
guten Abend guten Abend so kräftig
zugelegt im Vergleich zum letzten Mal
ist das jetzt ein Ergebnis über oder
auch ein bisschen unter ihren
Erwartungen wir haben trotz widriger
Umstände das beste Ergebnis
voraussichtlich wenn es so bleibt was
wir je hatten in Niedersachsen das ist
ein riesen Vertrauensvorschuss dafür zu
bedanken aber das ist auch ein großer
Auftrag dass wir auch regieren und
dementsprechend ein riesenglückwunsch an
unsere Leute in Niedersachsen vor allem
unsere
Spitzenkandidatinnen Julia Hamburg und
und Christian Meyer die die hier die
Lokomotive waren für diesen Wahlkampf
und jetzt gilt das dass wir das auch
umsetzen eine gute Politik für
Niedersachsen ich muss noch mal im
Moment beim Ergebnis bleiben denn sie
sagen ja es ist das beste für
Niedersachsen aber bei der
Bundestagswahl haben die Grünen letztes
Jahr hier mehr geholt also irgendwas ist
da schon passiert war da so ein kleiner
Habeck Dämpfer jetzt drin in diesem
Ergebnis zwischenzeitlich lang sie in
den Formfragen mal über 20 Prozent wie
Umfragen sind immer Zwischenstände und
Bundestagswahlen sind immer anders als
und wenn auch andere Faktoren von
anderen Faktoren entschieden als
Landtagswahlen und dementsprechend ist
das was jetzt passiert ist ein gutes
Ergebnis für uns und wir sind bereit sie
Verantwortung in diesem Land zu
übernehmen und ich gehe davon aus dass
wenn die Mehrheiten am Ende ausreichend
sind und dafür sieht es ja gerade sehr
gut dass Stefan weil auch uns zu
Gesprächen einlädt und unsere Leute dann
mit dem Koalitionsverhandlungen das
heißt also die Zeichen stehen klar für
Sie auf rot-grün ich finde wenn die
Umfragen die wir jetzt sehen auch die
Endergebnisse sind dann ist das sehr
eindeutig dass das stabile Auftrag ist
dann können wir an dieser Stelle den
spd-generalsekretär vielleicht dazu
nehmen ob der das schon genauso sieht
ich begrüße Sie herzlich in Berlin Kevin
Kühnert schönen guten Abend
guten Abend Frau Schausten hallo so ein
erfolgreicher Abend für die SPD und ist
es für sie auch schon so klar wie mit
nuripur gerade sagt die Zeichen stehen
jetzt auf rot-grün
also der Respekt gebietet es jetzt
erstmal abzuwarten bis wir dann
irgendwann am Abend ein amtliches
Endergebnis haben es gibt ja auch noch
Parteien die auf der Kippe stehen aber
für uns ist das das werden Sie verstehen
jetzt natürlich erstmal ein erfreulicher
Zwischenstand sieht sehr danach aus dass
Stefan weil mit der Niedersachsen SPD
diese Wahl gewonnen hat und dass das
Ziel was die SPD sich dort vorgenommen
hat nämlich ein Regierungswechsel hin zu
Rot-Grün machen zu können dass das wohl
auch funktioniert und das ist auch
notwendig in deutschland braucht mehr
Landesregierungen die nicht die
Bundesregierung herausfordern um sich in
einem kleinen Streits zu behakeln
sondern wir brauchen mehr
Landesregierungen den Verantwortung für
das große Ganze übernommen wird dafür
Stefan weil angetreten und gewählt
worden und ich glaube im Wechsel hin zur
Rot-Grün würde diesem Willen der
Wählerinnen und Wähler auch am besten
entsprechen
und Stefan weil macht ihnen natürlich
macht der Bundes-SPD durchaus auch ein
Geschenk über 30 Prozent im Bund liegt
die SPD im Moment so bei 17 18 Prozent
würden sie gleich wohl sagen Herr
Kühnert ist auch ein Sieg für Olaf
Scholz
die Menschen in Niedersachsen haben eine
Entscheidung für Ihr Bundesland
getroffen aber Stefan weil es eben einer
der die Zusammenarbeit mit der
Bundesregierung und auch mit Olaf Scholz
sucht er hat in den vergangenen Wochen
immer wieder gesagt die
entlastungspakete aus Berlin und jetzt
auch der Abwehrschirm mit den 200
Milliarden damit wir Wärme und Strom
Bremsen in Deutschland einführen können
es sind ganz wichtige Entscheidungen die
ihm auch dabei helfen sein Bundesland
Niedersachsen gut durch diese Krise
durchbringen zu können und insofern ist
das ein Vorgehen der
Partnerschaftlichkeit der Bundeskanzler
ist gestern noch zur
Wahlkampfunterstützung vor Ort gewesen
von Distanz kann da also keine Rede sein
sondern wir stehen da Schulter an
Schulter seit an seit und wir gewinnen
dann eben auch an solchen Abenden
gemeinsam
Herr nur Frage an den Grünen wie wird
jetzt dieses Ergebnis sich auswirken auf
die Ampel in Berlin wir sehen eine
schwächelnde FDP die an der Kippe ist es
eine Zitterpartie noch für die Liberalen
heute Abend
wird da der Ton noch mal krawalliger
werden jetzt zwischen grünen und FDP zu
mal ich hoffe sehr dass mein persönlich
meine persönliche Hoffnung dass die FDP
in den Landtag auch einzieht und gerade
in Zeiten in denen die
afd-ergebnisse hat die wirklich
erschreckend sind für die Demokratie und
es den Schulterschluss der
demokratischen Parteien braucht ist das
selbstverständlich dass wir natürlich
alle aufgerufen sind dem auch
Paroli zu bieten und deshalb ist das
notwendig auch mit der eigenen Koalition
auch zu Beginn und das machen wir auch
in der Ampel und arbeiten vertrauensvoll
miteinander zusammen und das wird sich
jetzt fortsetzen müssen ich gehe nicht
davon aus dass Niedersachsen und
Bundestagswahlen am Ende jetzt
durcheinander gemischt werden es sollte
auch niemand machen
Herr kühne hat noch mal Nachfrage nach
Berlin zur SPD was bedeutet das
fdp-ergebnis für die Ampel muss der
Bundeskanzler muss Olaf Scholz jetzt
umso mehr die FDP Stützen in der Ampel
nein also jeder Koalitionspartner
arbeitet unter den Bedingungen des
Koalitionsvertrages und einer
partnerschaftlichen Zusammenarbeit aber
schon natürlich dann auch für sich am
Ende ich glaube das würde Herr Lindner
auch nicht wollen dass wir jetzt
sozusagen den großen Bruder für die FDP
spielen aber was wir alle verstanden
haben sollten ist in Zeiten der Krise
möchten Großteil dieser Gesellschaft
enger zusammenrücken möchte weniger
Streit haben und stärker Ergebnisse
präsentiert kriegen diese Botschaft ist
angekommen und sie muss die
Zusammenarbeit der Ampeln den nächsten
Wochen und Monaten noch stärker prägen
als das bisher der Fall gewesen ist
Dankeschön Kevin Kühnert nach Berlin und
danke hier ins Studio mit Nuri pur der
Grünen Bundesvorsitzende so und dann
vertiefen wir jetzt das
fdp-ergebnis und schauen zunächst mal
wie diese fünf Prozent aus der Prognose
aufgenommen worden
ja man hat hier natürlich gehofft eine
auf man hat hier natürlich auf eine ganz
leichte Erleichterung gehofft dadurch
dass oder man hat hier gehofft dass er
eben dann doch die FDP über die fünf
Prozent kommt und sicher im Landtag ist
und das ist eben nicht eingetreten es
wurde hier dann trotzdem geklatscht auch
eben bei diesen fünf Prozent aber das
war dann wohl eher ein Mut machen
gegenseitig großes Raunen dann eben auch
bei der Zahl der AFD man hatte hier auch
ein bisschen darauf spekuliert eben über
diese fünf Prozent zu kommen und bei
einem schwachen Ergebnis für Rot-Grün
vielleicht sogar die Möglichkeit zu
haben an einer Regierungsbildung
beteiligt zu sein auch daran darin sieht
daran nach sieht es im Moment nicht aus
falls die FDP tatsächlich und das wird
sich ja im Laufe des Abends rausstellen
tatsächlich nicht über diese fünf
Prozent kommt nicht im Landtag vertreten
ist dann wird das ein Desaster sein
nicht nur für die Landes FDP sondern
eben auch für die
bundes-fraktionschef im Deutschen
Bundestag Christian Dürst zu uns
gekommen schönen guten Abend Herr dürr
sie sind auch Niedersachsen sie waren
viele viele Jahre im Landtag von
Hannover kennen hier die Verhältnisse
sehr gut und über 20 Jahre war die FDP
hier schon eine stabile Größe das muss
ein sehr enttäuschender Abend für Sie
sein und was ist eigentlich passiert
Ziel ist dass sie das natürlich
weiterhin ist aber lassen Sie mich
zunächst sagen glückwunsch auch an die
SPD und an Stefan weil es zeigt ja dass
ein an tierender ministerientier wieder
eine Wahl gewonnen hat und dass das was
die Union versucht hat offensichtlich
nicht verfangen hat nämlich einen Anti
ampelwahlkampf zu machen und damit
erfolgreich zu sein die Zeiten sind sehr
herausfordert und schwer genug für ganz
Deutschland in diesem Eindruck war
sicherlich auch dieser Landtagswahlkampf
kein leichter für uns ist jetzt noch zu
früh zu sagen wie es am Ende ausgeht
aber natürlich bleibe ich optimistisch
es ist eine Zitterpartie das kann ein
langer Abend werden für Sie und das
Ergebnis wird in jedem Fall nicht mehr
strahlend werden selbst wenn sie es noch
schaffen in den Landtag ist das ein
Stück auch die Quittung fürs mitregieren
in der Berliner Ampel also wir haben
beim letzten Mal 7,5% gehabt nach den
nach der jetzigen Prognose werden 2,5%
Punkte weniger das schmerzt natürlich
keine Frage aber wir haben 2021
entschieden dass wir Verantwortung fürs
Land übernehmen weil auch die Union zu
dem Zeitpunkt nicht regierungsfähig war
und das bleibt dabei wie übernehmen
Verantwortung für Deutschland das Ziel
ist auch dass in Niedersachsen übrigens
zu tun und ich will hinzufügen bei den
herausfordernden Zeiten verbieten sich
glaube ich Spielchen an der Stelle und
auch sagen wir mal schieferanalysen
sondern es geht jetzt darum sehr
konzentriert weiter zu arbeiten denn wir
haben in den kommenden Wochen sehr
schwerwiegende Entscheidung zu treffen
gerade im Energiebereich und das darauf
fokussieren wir uns dabei bleibt es auch
sie wollen also Verantwortung übernehmen
nach wie vor dabei bleibt es auch wenn
im Bund wenn die FDP hier im Land es
nicht über die 5% schaffen soll
angetreten für Verantwortung 2021 die
Ampel ist kein leichtes Bündnis für die
FDP das war von Anfang an klar
nichtsdestotrotz und und zwar das darf
ich hinzufügen zu dem Zeitpunkt als wir
die Regierung gebildet haben auch nicht
klar dass ein Krieg kommen würde dass
für eine veritable Inflation haben und
eine Energiekrise in ganz Europa das
sind jetzt herausfordernde Zeiten aber
die FDP stellt sich dieser Verantwortung
denn vor der läuft man nicht weg gerade
vor dem Hintergrund der schwierigen
Situation die wir haben letzte Frage
noch das ist natürlich auch für ihr im
Bundesvorsitzenden Christian Lindner der
ja Bundesfinanzminister ist in diesen
Zeiten jetzt ein schwieriges Ergebnis
kann man jetzt einfach so sagen weiter
so es hat sich ja kaum einen
Spitzenpolitiker einer Partei so
engagiert auch im Landtagswahlkampf wie
es Christian Lindner getan hat und
gleichzeitig haben wir schwierige
Herausforderungen in Berlin wegen der
Lage wegen des angriffskriegs auf die
Ukraine und dann geht es jetzt darum ans
Land zu denken und konzentriert
weiterzuarbeiten sag Christian dürr der
fDP-Fraktionschef im Bundestag vielen
Dank fürs Kommen danke so und wir
schauen jetzt mal aufs Ergebnis der AFD
die zu den klaren Gewinnern des heutigen
Abends gehört deutliche Gewinne das
Ergebnis vom letzten Mal fast verdoppelt
wir schauen mal wie die Stimmung ist und
gehen zu mal in ihlau
es hat hier gejault im Saal sie johlen
es kann nur einen geben ein Wahlsieger
geben und das ist die AFD der
Spitzenkandidat stefan matsischewski hat
es geschafft mit seiner Wahl mit seinem
Wahlziel von 12 Prozent das Feiern Sie
hier in einem Hotel etwas außerhalb von
Hannover
matsischewski ist ein Politik Neuling
das neue Gesicht der Niedersachsen AFD
ja und er muss jetzt diesen
zerstrittenen Landesverband
zusammenführen und die AFD die hat wohl
profitiert von der Energiekrise die
diesen ganzen Wahlkampf in Niedersachsen
dominiert hat aber trotz des Wahlsieges
heute für die AFD koalieren wird ja in
Niedersachsen keiner mit Ihnen
danke schön für die Eindrücke mal in
ihlau heute Abend von der Wahlparty der
AFD in der Tat ist es so dass sich die
afd-fraktion im Landtag von Hannover in
den letzten fünf Jahren wirklich
Schwerter Tat an eher dieser ströses
Bild abgegeben hat aber das hat nun
nicht geschadet das Ziel des
Spitzenkandidaten nämlich 12% zu
erreichen scheint erreicht und darüber
wollen wir sprechen jetzt mit Tino
krupala dem koopertal-chef der AFD und
auch Fraktionschef im Deutschen
Bundestag schönen guten Abend Herr
schönen guten Abend hallo
Sie haben ganz offenkundig von der
Krisenstimmung im Lande profitieren
können sie haben Proteststimmen
einsammeln können jetzt in dieser
Situation ist das auch ihre Erklärung
für Ihren Erfolg
ja wissen Sie wir haben als
Opposition hier nicht nur proteststimm
einsammeln können wir haben hier im
Prinzip eine klare Kante gezeigt und wir
haben ja Alleinstellungsmerkmale gehabt
indem wir unsere Politik aufgerichtet
haben an die Ursachen die wir derzeit
die Preissteigerung was Inflation angeht
was Energieknappheit angeht klar benannt
haben und nicht bloß an den Symptomen
herumgedocktert haben mit irgendwelchen
entlastungspaketen und Versprechungen
der Regierung die Ursachen sind
natürlich der Wirtschaftskrieg von
Habeck der hauptsächlich die eigene
Bevölkerung mittlerweile trifft die
Sanktionspolitik und das haben wir klar
benannt und das merken mittlerweile die
Bürger die mittelständischen Unternehmen
in ihrem Portemonnaies
aber man kann schon sagen darauf setzen
sie ja durchaus so ein Stück weit auch
Nutznießer der Krise zu sein unter der
viele Bürger natürlich jetzt leiden sich
Sorgen machen es gab
kürzlich so eine Szene dass der
afd-bundesvorstandskollege ihr Kollege
Harald weil
wörtlich sachte man müsste eigentlich
hoffen dass die Gaskrise schwierig
werden wenn nicht dramatisch genug wird
waren seine Worte dann geht so weiter
wie immer was zieht man daraus für
Schlüsse Herr krupala ist das das Motto
der AFD erst die Partei und dann das
Land
für uns geht es immer um das Land und
was wir gerade erleben wir stehen auch
an der Schwelle eines Dritten
Weltkrieges auch das muss man mal klar
benennen keine andere Partei benennt
überhaupt dieses Problem dass diese
Eskalationsstufe die auch von einer
Bundesregierung oder von Personen wie
Frau Strack Zimmermann oder auch selbst
Friedrich Merz immer weiter
vorangetrieben wird das sorgt die Leute
und ich möchte nicht dass meine Kinder
morgens aufwachen und im dritten
Weltkrieg Aufwachen wir brauchen eine
Deeskalation endlich
Friedensverhandlungen mit Russland das
trifft alles vor allem unsere Bürger und
unsere Wirtschaft unsere Wirtschaft geht
aktuell gerade vor die Hunde unser
Mittelstand kollabiert das sind die
Probleme die wir aktuell im Bundesgebiet
haben und darauf hat die Bundesregierung
keine Antworten sie macht einfach weiter
so
vielleicht lernt letzte Frage zu ihrem
Russland Kurs ihre Partei ist ja jetzt
nicht nur sie auch immer wieder auch
durch Äußerungen aufgefallen die einen
deutlich anderen Kurs schildern die auch
Wladimir Putins
Kurs hier eher Stützen
jüngste Parteifreund der Landeschef in
Sachsen Jörg urban hat gefordert die
völkerrechtlich nicht anerkennenden
scheinreferenten in der Ostukraine
anzuerkennen also warum stützen sie ist
die Frage als AFD Putins imperiale
Aggressionen
wieder von den eigentlichen Ursachen
ablenken wir sind eine klare
deutschlandpartei hier geht es um unsere
deutschen Interessen und das muss als
allererstes kommen und das haben wir
immer wieder in den Vordergrund
gestrickt wir brauchen eine
interessengeleitete Außenpolitik und
keine Werte geleitet der Außenpolitik
analog von Frau bärbock die uns ins
Verderben führt wir müssen uns mit allen
Ländern Europas und auch der Welt auf
der Art auch wirtschaftlich gut stellen
dass wir davon profitieren können und
dazu gehört auch Russland wir brauchen
weiterhin russisches Gas wir werden es
nicht kompensieren können mit nichts auf
der Welt wir kaufen jetzt aktuell für
200 Millionen Dollar pro Schiff gewinnen
für die Amerikaner teures dreckiges
trekkinggas aus der USA ein das kann
nicht so weitergehen das ist also der
Preis unserer Freunde wie wir sie ja
nennen die uns hier über den Tisch
ziehen wollen und das sprechen wir klar
an und ja Herr gropala nur zu
Konkretisierung das heißt sie
unterstützen keine Werte geleitete aus
dem Politik Deutschlands
nein es geht es geht in der Außenpolitik
immer um Interessen und das sehen wir
doch aktuell wer leidet denn am meisten
in Europa unter diesen Sanktionen das
ist hauptsächlich Deutschland unsere
Wirtschaft unser Mittelstand und das
kann uns nicht egal sein weil wenn die
Wirtschaft in der Mittelstand wegbricht
dann haben wir auch keine Chance mehr
Sozialleistungen unsere Bevölkerung an
unsere Rentner zu geben sagt der
Bundesvorsitzende der AFD tinokumpala
vielen Dank die AFD die ihr Ergebnis
hier verdoppeln konnte in der Prognose
bei 12% liegt und jetzt höre ich es gibt
eine erste Hochrechnung Matthias ja so
sieht es aus wir schauen uns mal an was
ich verändert hat im Vergleich zur
Prognose um 18 Uhr Hochrechnung 18.24
die SPD bei 32,7 Prozent die CDU 27,5
die Grünen 14,3 die FDP 5,0 nach wie vor
also auf der Kippe die AFD 11,8 Prozent
und die Linke 2,9 die alle anderen
zusammen 5,8 weil es so viel Bewegung
gab gucken wir uns jetzt noch mal an
eine eigene Graf zu Gewinnen und
Verlusten im Vergleich zur Wahl vor fünf
Jahren hier in Niedersachsen da verliert
die SPD viel mehr als vier Punkte die
CDU gewinnt etwa sechs Punkte verliert
extra sechs Punkte Entschuldigung die
Grünen gewinnen aber mehr als fünf
Prozentpunkte die FDP geht runter 2,5
Punkte die AFD deutliche Zuwächse auch
5,6 vergleichbar mit den Grünen und die
Linke verliert noch einmal war aber
ohnehin nicht im Landtag vertreten und
jetzt schauen wir mal was das heißt für
die Sitzverteilung im Landtag von
Hannover
135 ist die mindestsitzzahl und da käme
die SPD auf 49 die CDU auf 41 grüne 21
fdp7 wenn sie denn drin ist und die AFD
17 und wer könnte mit wem regieren die
möglichen Koalitionen
sehen wir hier die große Koalition die
derzeit amtiert hätte auch hier das ist
die Mehrheit die man braucht 68 sitze da
kommt sie klar drüber es will sie nur
niemand mehr so richtig SPD und Grüne
rot grün 70 das wäre also knapp drüber
aber immerhin zwei Sitze mehr als nötig
CDU und Grüne Schwarz-Grün kennen nicht
über diese Grenze hinweg und Jamaika
cdu-grüne und FDP wenn die denn drin ist
auf 69 das würde haarscharf reichen so
der stand im Moment ja Dankeschön und
das hat auch sich Hubertus Heil mit
angeschaut der Bundesminister für Arbeit
und Soziales in Berlin und
stellvertretender spd-bundesvorsitzender
und Niedersachsen das ist ja am heutigen
Abend auch nicht unwichtig Stimmen Namen
der heilen so das wird Ihnen gefallen
das ist ein deutlicher Abstand für die
SPD ein knappes allerdings Ergebnis für
Rot-Grün würden sie prognostizieren
gleichwohl das muss jetzt hier für
Rot-Grün ausgehen das ist erstmal ein
starker regierungsauf Stefan weil und
das erklärte Ziel ist SPD und Bündnis 90
die Grünen haben die größeren
Schnittmengen miteinander dass wenn es
reicht wir eine stabile Mehrheit für
Niedersachsen zustande bringen wir auch
gemeinsam regieren und wenn ich das noch
sagen darf es hat sich ausgezahlt dass
in diesen Zeiten den viele Menschen sich
Sorgen machen für viele Niedersachsen
meine Heimat unterwegs
Stefan bei Kurs gehalten hat und
besonnen und vernünftig und entschlossen
gehandelt hat das hat sich ausgezahlt
und deshalb ist es ein Auftrag für eine
neue Mehrheit in Niedersachsen eine neue
Mehrheit da hört man dann schon raus
Rot-Grün Herr Heil wir können jetzt uns
gerade mal die Spitzenkandidatin der
Grünen an hören die sich jetzt schon vor
ihre Parteianhänger gestellt hat
Julia Willi Hamburg haben wir doch mal
rein
wir freuen uns sehr wir freuen uns
wirklich sehr dass sie uns das Vertrauen
geschenkt haben dass sie zur Wahl
gegangen sind und ihre Kreuze bei den
Grünen gemacht haben und dass sie uns
damit auch deutlich gemacht haben dass
sie sich wünschen dass grüne
Niedersachsen Verantwortung übernehmen
und das werden wir jetzt auch tun wir
werden alles dafür geben als grüne
künftig Niedersachsen für die nächsten
fünf Jahre wieder zu gestalten und
zukunftsfest aufzustellen vielen vielen
Dank
so ja da hört man schon
regierungsanspruch auch heraus aber ich
will doch noch mal fragen Krisenzeiten
brauchen ja eigentlich auch große
stabile Mehrheiten was spricht denn
eigentlich gegen die Fortsetzung der
großen Koalition die CDU wer
offenkundiger dazu bereit für die US
klar abgewählt die SPD hat den
Regierungsauftrag mit Stefan weil und es
gibt ein Partner der mit uns regieren
will und es geht ja um zwei Dinge
erstens Niedersachsen und Deutschland
stabil durch schwierige Zeit durch die
Krise zu führen und gleichzeitig auch
dafür zu sorgen dass wir auch
Fortschritt machen niedersachsen will
Energieland Nummer eins werden
Niedersachsen braucht Investitionen und
auch eine Bildungspolitik die auf
Chancengerechtigkeit setzt da geht
Rot-Grün glaube ich mit Rot-Grün mehr
wir haben erlebt dass die CDU
Niedersachsen in den letzten Jahren eher
Bremsklotz war als fortschrittsmotor und
deshalb freue ich mich heute erstmal
ganz persönlich für Stefan weil und
sehen Sie es mir nach ich bin heute
verdammt stolz auf meine Niedersachsen
die in diesen Zeiten sturmfest gekämpft
haben das will ich Ihnen gar nicht
nehmen mich interessiert gleich wo sie
sind Mitglied der ampelregierung in
Berlin wie wichtig ist dieser
spd-sieg in Niedersachsen auch für Olaf
Scholz bringt er so ein bisschen
Entlastung das ist vor allem erstmal
Sieg der niedersächsischen SPD und von
Stefan weil es war ein landespolitische
Themen der Versuch der CDU gegen die
ampelpolitik zu machen und Wahlkampf die
hatten ja kein niedersächsisches Thema
ist auch gescheitert und ich würde mal
sagen heute Abend ist ein Willy
brandt-haus sicherlich mehr Freude als
im Konrad adenauer-haus das ist ja keine
Raketentechnik das zu begreifen aber
darum geht es nicht es geht darum dass
wir jetzt auch im Bundesrat
Unterstützung haben für einen Kurs der
dieses Land in schwierigen Zeiten
zusammenhält Stefan weil hat als
Ministerpräsident immer konstruktiv
mitgearbeitet und nicht mit Blockaden
gedroht und deshalb ist es ein wichtiger
Sieg für die niedersächsische SPD ist
aber auch gut für Deutschland ich freue
mich natürlich sieht man schon dass der
Wahlsieger des heutigen Abends kommt
vielleicht hört man auch was werden mal
rein wird jetzt erstmal noch abgeschirmt
aber wird dann sicherlich sich über kurz
oder lang zu Wort melden darauf warten
wir gerne letzte Frage Herr Heil sie
sind sozialmin dieses Landes die AFD hat
sich hier verdoppelt in Niedersachsen
und nimmt für sich wir haben gerade den
Bundesvorsitzenden gehört für sich in
Anspruch als einzige sich so um die
Sorgen in diesem Land um die Sorgen der
Menschen zu kümmern das kann sie nicht
erfreuen wie lange kann sich die
Regierung jetzt noch Zeit lassen um den
Bürgern wirklich echte
entlastungsperspektiven zu geben wir
geben die entlassungsperspektive als
darum geht das in dieser Zeit in der
Putin unsere Gesellschaft versucht zu
destabilisieren mit Gas als Waffe bin
ich zulassen dürfen dass die
Gesellschaft auseinander getrieben wird
und deshalb die
Rechtsradikalen von der AFD hat mir hier
kein Programm außer dass sie Ängste
geschürt haben und Menschen
gegeneinander ausgespielt haben und der
bessere Weg ist die gesamte Gesellschaft
im Blick zu haben deshalb wird es nach
den entlastungspaketen auch notwendig
sein die Gaspreise zu deckeln und dass
das Thema der nächsten Woche wir halten
Deutschland zusammen wir halten
Deutschland auf Kurs das ist unser Weg
aber wir lassen nicht zu dass Gruppen in
der Gesellschaft gegeneinander
ausgespielt werden wie das die
Rechtsradikalen von der A machen und wir
werden uns auch mit denen intensiv
auseinandersetzen die versuchen das
Klima zu vergiften und letztlich ja
eigentlich auch die Politik von Herrn
Putin in Deutschland sozusagen populär
zu machen wir haben das gerade im
Interview mit dem afd-vorsitzenden
gehört das ist unverantwortlich und
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir das Land
auf Kurs halten und das eigentlich ein
Aufruf an alle demokratischen Parteien
nicht nur meine
konstruktiv mitzuhelfen dieses Land
durch schwierige Zeiten zu führen und
eine große Aufgabe vielen Dank Hubertus
Heil für den Besuch im Studio ja
Hubertus Heil der sich freut für seine
niedersächsische SPD weniger Freude
macht der CDU das Ergebnis des heutigen
Abends ganz klar auf Platz zwei
verwiesen und darüber kann ich jetzt
sprechen mit dem stellvertretenden
cdu-bundesvorsitzenden Carsten Linnemann
der mir zugeschaltet ist schönen guten
Abend Herr Linnemann ja das ist wirklich
das schlechteste Ergebnis seit
Jahrzehnten geradezu wie enttäuscht sind
sie heute Abend
nein man muss einfach ehrlich sein dass
die Menschen Stefan Wall gewählt haben
ganz klar als Person sie sind völlig
verunsichert ich bekomme das auch mit es
gibt zum Teil Kriegsangst in Deutschland
und alle Studien zeigen auch dass man
dann diejenigen wählt die jetzt gerade
an der Macht sind und diesen Amtsbonus
hat er weil volle Pulle ausgespielt und
deswegen Glückwunsch gleichwohl war ja
auch Herr Althusmann in der Regierung
war Wirtschaftsminister Herr Linnemann
wir gucken uns mal ein paar Analysedaten
von der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen an die
vielleicht etwas aussagen über das
cdu-ergebnis Matthias sehr gerne Bettina
wir gucken mal auf die Bewertung von
Personen und Parteien hier durch die
Wählerinnen und Wähler in Niedersachsen
und da sehen wir auf einer Skala von +5
bis -5 Bernd Althusmann den CDU
Spitzenkandidaten bei 1,2 das ist ein
ganz in Ordnung Wert sage ich mal nicht
überragend aber okay Friedrich Merz der
CDU Parteivorsitzende aber wird hier in
Niedersachsen mit -0,2 negativ wenn es
also überhaupt einen Wind gab dann war
es kein Rückenwind für die CDU hier
sondern Gegenwind und das sehen wir auch
hier die CDU im Land wird doch klar
besser bewertet als die im Bund und
jetzt schauen wir noch mal es geht ja
nicht nur um Personen auf die
kompetenzzuweisungen die hier
vorgenommen werden das sind die drei top
Themen die die Menschen uns gesagt haben
in Niedersachsen
Energiesicherheit hohe Preise Schule
Bildung und da sehen wir können wir
ruhig alle Balken gleichzeitig fahren
bei allen führt die SPD deutlich man
misst ihr die höchste Lösungskompetenz
zu da sieht man dass die CDU der
schwarze Balken manchmal nicht so weit
weg ist aber es reicht halt nicht für
die höchste Kompetenz in der Tat und das
kann man noch ergänzen denn auch
Wirtschaftskompetenz wurde stärker der
SPD zugeschrieben Herr Linnemann das
muss ihnen besondere Sorgen machen
ja klar wir sind noch nicht am Ziel wir
sind auf gutem Wege wir haben die
Bundestagswahl mit voller Wucht verloren
und das kann man nicht von heute auf
morgen umsetzen wir müssen schnell auf
30% kommen das dauert noch ein wenig
aber jetzt kühlen Kopf bewahren Herr
altusmann war mit in der Regierung es
ist natürlich unglaublich schwierig wenn
du selbst regierst dann zu sagen wenn
ich regiere alleine mache ich alles
besser weil er war ja mit dabei so und
deshalb Glückwunsch an Herrn Wein man
muss schauen was heute Abend noch bei
rauskommt aber erst der klare Wahl
Sieger aber offenbar bestimmte ja die
Strategie nicht wirklich die Friedrich
Merz der Bundesvorsitzende eingeschlagen
hat mit dieser Attacke gegen die Ampel
in Berlin sich abzusetzen war das ein
Fehler
nein es war kein Fehler wir haben jetzt
seit sieben Monaten Krieg und es wird
einfach nicht gehandelt ich weiß mir
glaubt man das nicht wenn ich das sage
weil man denkt es ist Parteitaktik aber
die Bürgerinnen und Bürgern spüren
nichts und die Unternehmen auch nicht
das Gegenteil ist richtig wenn Friedrich
Merzig nicht so eingesetzt hätte meine
Meinung wäre das Ergebnis schlechter
gewesen die Menschen wollen Stabilität
und Herr weil hat diese Stabilität
diesen Menschen anscheinend gegeben das
muss man respektieren und so ist es
gelaufen Cars Linnemann der
stellvertretende CDU-Bundesvorsitzende
vielen Dank nach Berlin mit Respekt für
den Wahlsieger Stefan weil der sich
jetzt seinen Anhängern stellt und da
wollen wir natürlich live reingehen
wir stehen jetzt am Ende eines harten
man kann auch sagen eines sehr
unangenehm Wahlkampf
wir haben Wochen erlebt die
gekennzeichnet gewesen sind von tiefen
Sorgen der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
und ich möchte mich als allererstes
herzlich bedanken bei all denjenigen
Helferinnen und Helfern die in einer
schweren Situation immer wieder auch die
Diskussion gesucht haben die sich
manches am anhören müssen und ich kann
sagen ich bin ungeheuer stolz darauf
Vorsitzender eines Landesverbandes mit
solchen Mitgliedern zu sein herzlichen
Dank
[Applaus]
vor diesem Hintergrund kann ich sagen
wir haben gewonnen wir haben gekämpft
und wir haben heute abend gewonnen liebe
Freunde und liebe Freunde
[Applaus]
nach
nach allen Zahlen nach allen Umfragen
die ich kenne ist die SPD mit weitem
Abstand die stärkste Partei wir haben
die stärkste Fraktion im
niedersächsischen Landtag die
Wählerinnen und Wähler haben der SPD den
Regierungsauftrag erteilt und niemand
anders sonst das ist das Ergebnis des
heutigen Abend
so Stefan weil der Wahlsieger des
heutigen Abends gekämpft und gewonnen
dass war seine Aussage und in der Tat
liegt mit weitem Abstand von gut fünf
Prozentpunkten vor der CDU und macht
hier heute Abend das Rennen das wird ich
nehme das an den
spd-bundesvorsitzenden Lars Klingbeil
der mir jetzt in Berlin zugeschaltet ist
sehr Freund schön guten Abend Herr
Klingbeil und noch ein Niedersachsen
einer der zufrieden ist heute Abend
schönen guten Abend aus Berlin und in
der Tat sie sehen hier ein sehr
zufriedenen Parteivorsitzenden war
selbst viele Niedersachsen unterwegs in
meinem Heimatbundesland wir haben
gekämpft Stefan weil und die SPD
Niedersachsen haben gewonnen und das
fühlt sich gerade in diesen turbulenten
Zeiten schon sehr gut an aber das ist
schon söhnlichkeitsseg für Stefan weil
würden Sie dem zustimmen also in
Niedersachsen versammelt man sich
vielleicht auch aus Sorge vor dem was
jetzt im Winter kommt hinter dem was man
kennt und dem Kandidaten den man
vertraut oder ist dies hier heute auch
eine Bestätigung für die Politik der
ampelregierung und Olaf Scholz erstmal
haben die Niedersachsen entschieden wer
künftig hier Bundesland führen soll und
das Votum ist deutlich Stefan weil hat
sich in den letzten knapp zehn Jahren
als Ministerpräsident ein großes
Vertrauen erarbeitet er hat eine starke
Regierungsmannschaft der hat eine starke
Fraktion der niedersächsische
Landesverband ist gut aufgestellt diese
Arbeit ist bestätigt worden aber muss
auch sagen wir haben als SPD
zusammengekämpft wir waren alle da der
Bundeskanzler die Parteivorsitzenden wir
haben alle mit der SPD in Niedersachsen
und es eng abgestimmt in den letzten
Wochen und insofern kann man schon sagen
das ist auch ein gemeinsamer Erfolg ein
Erfolg der uns auch auf Bundesebene gut
tut aber vor allem ist es in der Tat das
große Verdienst von Stefan weil
dann hören wir uns vielleicht dazu mal
kurz ein Stückchen Analyse an kurze
Analyse zum spd-ergebnis das wird sie ja
auch interessieren mit TS vorne ja so
ähnlich wie gerade bei der CDU kamen bei
der SPD auch auf Personen und Parteien
in Land und in Bund und dann jetzt sind
wir erstmal bei der falschen Grafik das
ist die richtige da sehen wir das auf
der Skala von plus 5 bis -5 die
Bewertung für den amtierenden
Ministerpräsidenten Stefan weil
+2,1 ein Punkt besser ist als die für
seinen Herausforderer und deutlich
besser als für den amtieren
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz der nur auf
0,9 kommt was die Parteien betrifft SPD
im Land 2,0 im Bund 1,3 da sieht man das
ist der niedersächsischen SPD ein Stück
weit gelungen ist sich zu entkoppeln von
einer kritischen Bewertung der
Bundespartei und des Bundeskanzlers es
hast du etwas noch aus der
wahltagsbefragung an den Wahllokalen wer
hat die SPD gewählt nach Altersgruppen
da sehen wir bei den unter 30-Jährigen
klare Verluste das zieht sich so durch
stabil aber bleibt es bei den über
60-Jährigen 42 Prozent das ist
ungewöhnlich gut für die SPD das ist
eigentlich eine Domäne der CDU die hat
vor fünf Jahren die SPD hier erobert und
jetzt gehalten das ist ein Teil des
erfolgsgeheimnisses die alten haben die
SPD die Älteren haben die SPD gewählt
und
es war das zeigten die ersten Zahlen
Herr Klingbeil schon auch wirklich ein
starker Sieg von Stefan weil selbst ich
will jetzt noch mal fragen ist für sie
für den Bundesvorsitzenden Rot-Grün
jetzt gesetzt in Hannover in
Niedersachsen also klar ist die Frage
wie die künftige Regierungskoalition
aussieht wird in Niedersachsen
entschieden Stefan weil hat im Wahlkampf
immer deutlich gemacht wenn es eine
rot-grüne Mehrheit gibt dann will er die
greifen und er will das Rot-Grün regiert
und danach sieht es stand jetzt hier aus
das Rot-Grün möglich ist und dann bin
ich mir sicher wird es diese
Regierungskoalition die in Niedersachsen
ja schon sehr lange sehr erfolgreich in
den letzten Jahren zusammengearbeitet
dann wird es die jetzt auch wieder geben
weil das wäre dann die Rückkehr zu zu
Rot-Grün zwischen 2013 und 17 letzte
Frage nochmal Auswirkungen auf dem Bund
die Schwäche der FDP wie wird das die
Ampel belasten was glauben Sie wir
warten jetzt mal ab bis alles ausgezählt
ist ich rede jetzt hier als
SPD-Vorsitzender aber natürlich gucken
wir genau wie die anderen Ergebnisse
auch sind aber wissen Sie in der Ampel
sind wir dann erfolgreich in Berlin wenn
wir uns unterhaken wenn wir gut
zusammenarbeiten wenn wir nicht
aufteilen nach Parteifarben sondern wenn
wir die bestmöglichen Lösungen für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger hinbekommen wir
haben jetzt eine große Verantwortung den
gaspreismassiv zu senken dazu wird es
morgen Vorschläge geben und das muss
dann von der Ampel auch gemeinsam
getragen werden da sollte man nicht in
parteipolitisches denken verfallen
sondern geschlossen in der Ampel
gemeinsam agieren und das ist das worum
es geht der Appell des
spd-bundesvorsitzenden vielen Dank Herr
Klingbeil nach Berlin und jetzt schauen
wir hier wieder im Land Niedersachsen
auf den
CDU-Spitzenkandidaten der hier
Ministerpräsidenten ablösen wollte aber
nun doch sehr klar auf Rang 2 verwiesen
wurde Bernd Althusmann
meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Liebe Parteifreunde Herr
fraktionsvorsitzender
ich darf mich für den freundlichen
Applaus und die Begrüßung hier aus
herzlichste bedanken ich danke aber in
erster Linie den Wählerinnen und Wählern
in Niedersachsen die heute Abend einen
offensichtlich klares Votum
herbeigeführt haben
ich danke meinem Team ich danke allen
die mich in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten die Fraktion das Wilfried
hasselmann-haus mein Team der Junge
Union nie ohne mein Team
wir sind hier gemeinsam viele Wochen in
einem anstrengenden Wahlkampf der war
wahrscheinlich noch nie so stark
herausfordernd war wie in dieser Zeit
gemeinsam vorangegangen um für unsere
Überzeugung zu werben
wir haben unser Wahlziel stärkste Kraft
in Niedersachsen zu werden auf jeden
Fall nicht erreicht
dieses Votum nehmen wir demütig an auch
ich persönlich nehme dieses Votum an die
Wählerinnen und Wähler haben der SPD
einen klaren Regierungsauftrag erteilt
dieser Regierungsauftrag ist eine hohe
Verantwortung ich wünsche dem
voraussichtlich künftigen
Ministerpräsidenten Stefan weil und
seiner SPD an dieser Stelle viel Erfolg
für die Zukunft es geht um unser Land in
schwierigen Zeiten ist dieses eine
besondere Herausforderung aber es gehört
sich glaube ich auch für ein politischen
Mitbewerber dass wir zunächst einmal
auch denjenigen die die Wahl
offensichtlich erfolgreich absolviert
haben ein klares Votum erreicht haben
auch gratulieren auch da Bernd
Althusmann ja das muss man sagen der
Wahl Verlierer am heutigen Abend
Spitzenkandidat der CDU und da zeigt ein
wahlverlehrer durchaus Statur räumt die
Niederlage ein und gratuliert dem Wahl
Sieger ja das war ein deutlich
schlechteres Ergebnis als erwartet
eine Zitterpartie ist es am heutigen
Abend noch für die FDP auf die wir jetzt
noch mal schauen wollen 5% in der
Prognose und der ersten Hochrechnung
noch nicht klar ob es reicht für den
Einzug weniger Wiedereinzug in den
Hannoveraner Landtag ich bin jetzt in
Berlin verbunden mit dem
Bundesvorsitzenden Christian Lindner
Herr Lindner ein bitterer Abend für sie
hoffen noch nämlich an
es ist ein Rückschlag für die FDP-Frau
Schausten das ist völlig klar wir
wollten dass die Politik der Mitte
gestärkt wird in Hannover sieht es jetzt
aus nach einer linken Mehrheit übrigens
hängt das wohl auch damit zusammen dass
die Union vor allen Dingen Wahlkampf
gegen die FDP gemacht hat nicht gegen
SPD und Grüne wir haben bundespolitisch
unseren Wahlkämpferinnen und
Wahlkämpfern aus Berlin aus der
Ampelkoalition heraus auch keinen
Rückenwind geben können denn viele
unserer Unterstützerinnen und
Unterstützer fremdeln mit dieser
Koalition und bedauerlich ist dass
unsere Positionierung die Laufzeit der
Kernkraftwerke zu verlängern auch von
den Wählerinnen und Wählern die das
genauso sehen wie wir in Niedersachsen
keine Unterstützung gefunden hat sie
sagen ihre wählerfremdeln mit dieser
Koalition heißt das das Ergebnis ist
hier heute tatsächlich die Quittung fürs
mitregieren der FDP in der Berliner
Ampel
sie sagen das Wort Quittung mit so einem
Unterton wir sind in der Ampel aus
staatspolitischer Verantwortung wir sind
in der Ampelkoalition auf
staatspolitischer Verantwortung nicht
weil SPD und Grüne uns von den
inhaltlichen Überzeugungen so nahe
stünden das würden die selber ja auch
nicht anders sehen und wir zahlen dafür
gewiss einen Preis bei unseren
politischen Profil weil manche die FDP
als liberale Kraft dann nicht erkennen
und glauben wir sein jetzt auch eine
linke Partei und keine mehr der Mitte
diese Rolle der FDP und diese
Wahrnehmung der FDP die werden wir uns
genau ansehen und überdenken
Helena sollen wir kurz einmal auf
Analysedaten schauen die vielleicht
interessant sind Matthias Fornoff sehr
gerne wir schauen auf die FDP und auf
die Bewertung aller Parteien in
Niedersachsen durch die Befragten hier
auf der Skala von +5 bis -5 SPD guter
Wert 2,0 CDU schlechter 0,9 aber positiv
grüne auch knapp 0,2 die FDP - 0,3 das
ist ein Wert der ist nicht Fisch nicht
Fleisch das ist nicht wirklich richtig
schlecht es ist aber schon gar nicht gut
und das zeugt davon dass es doch wenig
Durchschlagkraft der landesfdp hier gab
und wir schauen uns noch eine zweite
Grafik an die meint dann den Bund in der
Bundesregierung machen ihre Arbeit eher
gut sagt für die SPD 53 Prozent für die
Grünen 51% für die FDP nur 32 da sagt
eine Mehrheit 58 Prozent die FDP macht
ihre Ampel in der macht ihre Arbeit in
der Bundesregierung eher schlecht und
das ist natürlich in der Tat Gegenwind
ja Gegenwind Herr Lindner und das stützt
ihre These das natürlich ihr Wähler
Klientel fremdelt mit der FDP in dieser
ampelregierung ich würde sie gerne nach
den Konsequenzen jetzt fragen nach
diesem Ergebnis in Niedersachsen geht da
für sie als Bundesvorsitzender ein
weiter so in der Ampel
ich werde diese Frage heute Abend ganz
sicherlich nicht sinnvoll beantworten
können weil wir jetzt erstmal das
Ergebnis überschlafen müssen sorgfältig
analysieren müssen wo und was können und
müssen wir verändern allerdings ist die
Zahl die sie genannt haben in einer
Hinsicht interessant 32 Prozent sagen
die FDP leistet eine gute Arbeit in der
Bundesregierung davon haben in
Niedersachsen aber jetzt zu wenige die
FDP gewählt das deutet für mich auch auf
einen mobilisierungsproblem hin und an
diesen Fragen werden wir miteinander im
Team der Liberalen Familie sprechen aber
nicht öffentlich ja
das nur noch mal zur Klärung wenn sie
sagen also ein gewisser Anteil sieht die
Arbeit ja durchaus positiv das heißt sie
stellen jetzt auch ihre Mitarbeit in der
Ampel nicht zu Disposition auch dann
nicht wenn die FDP es in Niedersachsen
nicht in den Landtag schaffen sollte
Frau Schausten wir sind in einem
energiekrieg und einer Wirtschaftskrise
hier zählt staatspolitische
Verantwortung wir haben parteipolitisch
heute einen Rückschlag erlitten aber wir
stehen in Verantwortung für dieses Land
ich habe ein Amtsarzt geschworen ich
habe meine Liberalen Überzeugungen wir
haben unsere liberale Programmatik aber
wir wissen auch um unsere Verantwortung
für dieses Land und seine Menschen
Christian Lindner der
fdp-bundesvorsitzende mit einem klaren
Statement zur vorsetzung der
ampelregierung in Berlin ganz herzlichen
Dank Herr Lindner nach Berlin
so und wir hatten gerade Bernd
Althusmann den Spitzenkandidat der CDU
gehört der hat inzwischen auch
mitgeteilt dass er als
Landesvorsitzender der CDU weiter nicht
mehr zur Verfügung stehen wird er zieht
also die Konsequenzen aus diesem
Wahlergebnis eine erste dann auch
personalpolitische Konsequenz des
heutigen Abends jetzt schauen wir noch
einmal auf das grünen Ergebnis die
Grünen sind Gewinner am heutigen Abend
liegen in der letzten Prognose bei gut
14 Prozent das ist deutlich mehr fünf
Prozent fünf bis sechs Prozent mehr als
beim letzten Mal aber doch hatte der ein
oder andere mehr erwartet denn
zwischenzeitlich verhießen die
vorumfragen sogar mal 2022 Prozent die
Bundesvorsitzende Ricarda lang ist jetzt
in Berlin wird zugeschaltet schönen
guten Abend Frau lang ja kräftig
zugelegt im Vergleich zum letzten Mal
aber ist dieses ist dieses Ergebnis
jetzt über ihren Erwartungen oder hätten
sie doch ein bisschen mehr sich
gewünscht
natürlich hätten wir uns über ein paar
Prozent mehr ganz klar gefreut aber es
ist ein starkes Ergebnis es sind
deutliche Verbesserung zum letzten
Ergebnis und so wie es jetzt im Moment
aussieht ist es auch und historisch
bestes Ergebnis Niedersachsen vor allem
was mir aber wichtig ist ist es aus
meiner Sicht ein Auftrag der Wählerinnen
und Wähler dass wir auch in
Niedersachsen Verantwortung übernehmen
dafür stehen wir ganz klar bereit ich
glaube Niedersachsen hat ein
riesengroßes Potenzial das in den
letzten Jahren nicht genutzt wurde von
der rot-schwarzen Regierung ich hoffe
das können wir jetzt ändern bei
erneuerbaren Energien bei Klimaschutz
und auch bei sozialer Gerechtigkeit vor
lang wir wollen auch kurz mal ein
bisschen Analysedaten hier zu den Grünen
reinziehen in unser Gespräch sicherlich
interessant Matthias ja das ist das
Bettina machen wir gerne Analysedaten zu
den Grünen woher kommen die Wähler der
Grünen wer diesmal Grün gewählt hat hat
vor fünf Jahren die SPD gewählt das sind
21 Prozent in absoluten Zahlen 110.000
etwa das ist richtig viel die CDU etwa
halb so viel 50.000 die anderen
insgesamt 60.000 und Nichtwähler auch
das ein großer Brocken der sich für die
Grünen entschieden hat diesmal 110.000
Wählerinnen und Wähler und jetzt schauen
wir noch mal aus der wahltagsbefragung
an den Wahllokalen nach der
Altersstruktur derer die Grünen gewählt
haben wir sehen hier unten Zugewinne
überall in allen Altersklassen besonders
stark sind die Grünen bei den unter
30-Jährigen mit 20 Prozent jetzt das ist
der Bereich in dem die SPD haben wir
vorhin gesehen viel verloren hat und
noch eine weitere Grafik zum Thema
Bildung auch die ist ziemlich
eindrucksvoll je höher der
abbildungsabschluss desto eher die
Bereitschaft Grün zu wählen ja das ist
interessant Matthias Frau lang können
wir noch mal kurz vertiefen da haben sie
also offenkundig von den von der SPD
Wähler rüberziehen können zumal mehr
jüngere aber so richtig glasklar ist
diese rot-grüne Mehrheiten ich reicht
ihnen das eine Stimme über den Durst
erstmal muss man ganz klar feststellen
dass die Union in den letzten Wochen
versucht hat im Land aber auch im Bund
einen anti-ampelwahlkampf insbesondere
einen anti-rot-grünwahlkampf zu machen
und das ist ganz klar gescheitert auch
dafür wurden sie abgewählt wir stehen
bereit für Gespräche für eine rot-grüne
Regierungsbeteiligung wir gehen da ganz
klar mit einem inhaltlichen Anspruch an
aber ich glaube da wäre vieles drin für
dieses Land man könnte in Niedersachsen
zum Vorreiter machen bei einer
neuerbaren Energien die Wirtschaft dort
transformieren grüne neue Arbeitsplätze
schaffen und man kann zeigen dass man in
der Landwirtschaft mit ökologischer
Landwirtschaft erfolgreich ist ich
glaube das ist eine gute Chance Frau
lang gleichwohl ist es ja für die Grünen
läuft es auch nicht nur gut im Bund
siehe gasumlage von Robert Habeck was
ist aus ihrer Sicht das Signal für den
Bund wird es zwischen Grünen und der
angeschlagenen FDP jetzt noch stressiger
noch krawalliger
ich glaube es ist klar mit diesem
Wahltag aber auch unabhängig von diesen
Wahltag die Ampel trägten diese Zeit
eine riesengroße Verantwortung wir
müssen die Menschen durch den Winter
bringen indem wir jetzt die graspreise
Decken indem wir für
Versorgungssicherheit sorgen und
gleichzeitig den langen Blick nicht
verlieren also die erneuerbaren Energien
ausbauen irgendwie her dieser Klimakrise
werden und ich glaube das hat man ja
gerade auch bei Herr Lindner gehört dazu
stehen wir alle weiterhin bereit und
davon werden wir morgen und die Wochen
danach gemeinsam daran arbeiten sagt die
Bundesvorsitzende der Grünen Ricarda
langen herzlichen Dank nach Berlin
so die zweiten Gewinner an diesem Abend
in Niedersachsen sind die ist die AFD
die ihr Ergebnis vom letzten Mal
verdoppeln kann fast verdoppeln kann ein
zweistelliges klar zweistelliges
Ergebnis in der Hochrechnung jetzt bei
11,8 Prozent und der Spitzenkandidat ist
bei meinem Kollegen Peter Kunz im
Gespräch
bei mir im Landtag jetzt Stefan
marzischewski von der AFD auch ein
Wahlsieger des heutigen Abends mit 12%
fast verdoppelt was heißt das jetzt für
die AFD das heißt für die AFD dass wir
hier in Niedersachsen angekommen sind
dass wir auch in Westdeutschland
angekommen sind heißt das aufrufzeichen
auf auch für die Bundespartei dass wir
noch stärker werden in den nächsten
Jahren welche konstruktive Politik
werden sie dem Wähler dann anbieten der
in das Vertrauen geschenkt hat
konstruktiv heißt sachorientierte
Arbeiten konstruktive Lösungsvorschläge
zu machen für bessere Schulen für den
Erhalt der Förderschule lernen für mehr
Polizei die besser bezahlt wird für
Abschaffung der Straßenausbaubeiträge in
Niedersachsen Stefan marzischewski von
der AFD ich gebe zurück ins Wahlstudio
zu Bettina Schausten Dankeschön und fünf
Minuten vor der 19 Uhr heute Sendung
haben wir die zweite Hochrechnung
Matthias gemeinsam an
hier ist die Hochrechnung von 18.55 Uhr
die SPD jetzt doch über 33 Prozent 33,1
mit Verlusten die CDU war 27,9 mit noch
deutlicheren Verlusten die Grünen 14,1
gewinnen viel hinzu aber vielleicht
weniger als erwartet die FDP nach wie
vor um die fünf Prozent mit Verlusten
die AFD gewinnt deutlich dazu 11,8 und
die Linke klar nicht drin mit
2,7%. und jetzt gucken wir mal was das
an regierungsmöglichkeiten hier mit mit
sich bringt die große Koalition aus SPD
und CDU die käme locker über diese 68
Sitze die man mindestens braucht
rot-Grün käme auch drüber mit 70 sitzen
Schwarz-Grün nicht und Jamaika wenn die
FDP denn drin ist käme auch scharf auch
drüber aber ob die FDP drin ist ist
unklar ja danke schön Matthias für diese
so und jetzt darf ich schon mal fragen
bin verbunden mit dem Wahlsieger des
heutigen Abends Stefan weil mir jetzt
zugeschaltet sein müsste schönen guten
Abend Herr weil hallo Frau schorsten ich
grüße sie ja von Hannover nach Hannover
der dritte Wahlsieg für Sie nach 2013
und 2017 und trotz geringer Einbußen mit
klarem Abstand stärkste Kraft in
Niedersachsen wir erleichtert sind sie
heute Abend na klar bin ich erleichtert
das war wirklich sein ein sehr harter
man kann sagen ein sehr unangenehmer
Wahlkampf weil er geprägt war von tiefen
und ja auch nachvollziehbaren Sorgen von
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern und ich bin sehr
dankbar all denjenigen die in dieser
Zeit jetzt den Rücken gerade gemacht
haben und ich bin noch dankbarer dafür
dass unter solchen Bedingungen die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in Niedersachsen
wieder der SPD das Vertrauen
ausgesprochen haben selbstverständlich
ist das nicht ich empfinde es jedenfalls
nicht so hat Olaf Scholz schon
gratuliert
vielen Dank
haben sie Grund ihm zu danken oder nicht
eher vor allem ihnen dass sie ihm jetzt
einen spd-erfolg heute abend kredenzen
vielleicht können wir uns ja gegenseitig
danken ich bin jedenfalls dankbar dafür
dass die Bundesregierung unter extrem
schwierigen Bedingungen arbeitet jetzt
beispielsweise mit einem 200 Mark
milliardenprogramm gezeigt hat dass sie
aktiv an der Seite der BürgerInnen
Bürger und der Wirtschaft steht und ich
bin gespannt auf die Konkretisierung
aber das war ganz wichtig und umgekehrt
glaube ich dass wir in Niedersachsen
auch gezeigt haben auch in der
schwierigen Bedingung kann die SPD
Erfolg haben und ich wünsche mir dass
das auch in anderen Teilen Deutschlands
gelingt
vom herzlichen Dank dafür und das bauen
wir jetzt als kleinen Cliffhanger ein
also bis gleich in unserer 19 Uhr heute
Sendung vielen Dank an Stefan weil ja
und wir nutzen die eine Minute die wir
noch haben Professor Korte um mal kurz
einen Strich drunter zu ziehen was ist
hier heute Abend passiert es war schon
im Rahmen sozusagen das erwarteten aber
ein doch sehr klarer Sieg eine klare
Führung für die SPD eindeutig und in
diesen Zeiten ungewöhnlich es ist
veränderungszuversicht was offenbar
gewählt worden ist fast 90 Prozent hat
die Mitte stabilisiert in diesen Zeiten
indem wir nicht nur einen Krieg haben
sondern Angriff auf unsere Lebensalltag
und nicht richtig wissen wie wir damit
umgehen können unter diesen Bedingungen
ist das in der Mitte ein interessantes
Ergebnis was uns von allen anderen
Ländern fundamental unterscheidet eine
Wahl gleichwohl in Krisenzeiten und da
zeigt sich schon etwas bei der AFD geht
es deutlich raus
kann also sozusagen Protest Stimmen
einsammeln sie hat neunmal
hintereinander verloren jetzt hat sie
diesmal zugelegt und es zeigt natürlich
dass sie ein Profiteur der Krise ein
Profiteur der Ängste ist als Unmuts
aufsauger als frustventil sich gerade zu
eignet und mit Massenarmut und
Massenverarmung auch Themen gesetzt hat
um das resultiment zu bedienen aber sie
ist als Protestpartei für viele offenbar
wählbar aber eben in der Größenordnung
von 12 Prozent und nicht das was wir oft
annehmen große protestströme große
wutarien das ist nicht ablesbar für den
Moment vielen Dank auf das FDP Ergebnis
die an und um die fünf Prozent Hürde
liegt darauf müssen wir schauen wir
gehen jetzt erstmal direkt nach Mainz zu
unserer heute Sendung mit Barbara Halbig
[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
Willkommen an diesem Wahlsonntag
Christian Otto liefert den Formel 1
Weltmeister dazu genau Max Verstappen
hat es wieder geschafft guten Abend und
das sind die Nachrichten Themen von
heute
nach Landtagswahl in Niedersachsen
Ministerpräsident weil und seine SPD
klar vor der CDU grüne und AFD legen
deutlich zu die FDP muss um den Einzug
in den Landtag zittern
nach Sabotage und Bahnchaos weil ein
politisches Motiv nicht ausgeschlossen
wird ermittelt jetzt auch der
Staatsschutz
und nach Chaos Rennen und viel
Verwirrungen Red Bull Piloten Max
Verstappen wird vorzeitig Formel 1
Weltmeister zum zweiten Mal in Folge
[Musik]
die Wählerinnen und Wähler in
Niedersachsen setzen in der Krise auf
Bewährtes die SPD von Ministerpräsident
Stefan weil bleibt trotz
verlustenstärkste Partei und bekommt
vielleicht sogar ihre wunschkoalition
mit den Grünen die haben nämlich
deutlich dazu gewonnen wie auch die AFD
CDU-Spitzenkandidat und Parteichef
Althusmann hat wegen des schlechten
Abschneidens seiner Partei vor ein paar
Minuten seinen Rücktritt angekündigt die
FDP fliegt vielleicht sogar aus dem
Landtag gehen wir direkt ins ZDF
Wahlstudio zu Matthias Fornoff Matthias
wie sehen die neuesten Zahlen aus ja
guten Abend hier ist die neueste
Hochrechnung für 19 Uhr demnach kommt
die SPD auf 33,2 Prozent verliert aber
gegenüber von vor fünf Jahren die CDU 28
% mit noch deutlicheren Verlusten die
Grünen 14,0 auch mit zu gewinnen die FDP
5,0 auf der Kippe ob sie reinkommt
verliert relativ deutlich die AFD 11,7
Prozent mit deutlichen Zugewinnen und
die Linke 2,7% definitiv nicht im
Landtag vertreten die sonstigen 5,4
Prozent zusammen und jetzt schauen wir
mal was das heißt für die Möglichkeit zu
regieren hier in Niedersachsen die
Anzahl der Sitze die man braucht für die
absolute Mehrheit ist diese senkrechte
Linie 68 die amtierende große Koalition
käme auf 91 das wäre also rechnerisch
gar kein Problem die Frage ist auf
politisch gewollt ist Rot-Grün 69 knapp
drüber würde reichen Schwarz-Grün würde
nicht reichen und wenn denn die FDP drin
ist wir haben es gesehen das ist knapp
dann ginge auch Jamaika haarscharf
die SPD ist wieder stärkste Partei wie
ist das zu erklären allein durch die
Popularität des Ministerpräsidenten
na das ist sicher ein Faktor Stefan weil
hat hier einen klaren Amtsbonus gehabt
bei den Wählerinnen und Wählern in
Niedersachsen die allermeisten wollten
ihn behalten und keinen Wechsel hin zum
CDU Herausforderer aber man muss auch
sagen bei den drei Top-Themen die die
Leute hier nennen das ist
Energiesicherheit wie in ganz
Deutschland das sind die explodierenden
Preise und das ist aber auch Schule und
Bildung bei allen drei Themen steht die
SPD vorn was die Lösungskompetenz
betrifft es ist also eine Mischung aus
Personen die funktioniert haben und
Kompetenzen Dankeschön Mathias Fornoff
Niedersachsen war das letzte Bundesland
das von einer großen Koalition regiert
wird und dieses Bündnis dürfte jetzt
wohl auch bald beendet sein wir gehen
wieder ins ZDF-Studio nach Hannover zu
Bettina Schausten die jetzt den
Ministerpräsidenten und einige der
Spitzenkandidaten befragt Bettina so ist
es das gehört natürlich zu Routine des
wahlabends dazu da wollen wir die
Reaktionen hören und wir beginnen beim
Wahlsieger des heutigen Abends beim
Ministerpräsident Stefan weil Herr Wald
ja großer Erfolg zum zweiten Mal wieder
gewählt können Sie jetzt in eine dritte
Amtszeit starten und haben die Wahl
weiter mit der CDU oder eben den Grünen
das reicht läuft es jetzt auf rot-grün
hinaus ich habe vor den Wahlen ja gesagt
was meine bevorzugte Präferenz ist das
ist Rot-Grün das haben wir aber eben
auch gesehen na das könnte durchaus der
knapp sein und die Niedersachsen kennen
wir durchaus auch lange wahlabende aber
wenn es danach reicht dann bleibe ich
bei meiner Präferenz für eine rot-grüne
Landesregierung
weiter mit Bernd Althusmann
Spitzenkandidat der CDU der heute Abend
schon die Konsequenz aus seiner
Niederlage gezogen hat aber sie waren
angetreten um Stefan weil hier als
Ministerpräsident abzulösen der
Althusmann das hat nicht geklappt die
Wähler haben sie auf Platz zwei
verwiesen was sind die Gründe für diese
Niederlage und sie denken auch nicht
mehr an eine große Koalition
man darf hier nichts schön reden das ist
eine bittere Niederlage für die Union in
Niedersachsen wir wollten stärkste Kraft
werden dieses Ziel haben wir nicht
erreicht wir haben ein engagierten
Wahlkampf geführt sind aber mit unseren
Themen offensichtlich nicht
durchgedrungen unter Umständen könnte
natürlich der Amtsbonus das wurde schon
erwähnt ein entscheidender Punkt gewesen
sein in Krisen dann versammeln sich
viele Menschen dann doch hinter dem
Ministerpräsidenten das ist ganz
offensichtlich über Jahrzehnte in
Deutschland so aber ich sage auch
kritisch wir müssen als CDU in
Niedersachsen wie auch er als CDU in
Deutschland etwas tiefer schürfen wir
können die letzte Bundestagswahl und ich
denke auch die letzten 16 Jahre der
CDU-Regierung auf Bundesebene nicht
einfach ausblenden auch das war Thema
immer wieder im Wahlkampf und insofern
ist es uns nicht ausreichend gelungen
mit unseren Vorschlägen zur
Bildungspolitik mit unseren Vorschlägen
für ein Energieland mit unseren
Vorschlägen für eine starke Wirtschaft
in Niedersachsen so zu punkten dass wir
vor der SPD gelegen hätten und bei mir
kam hinzu ich bin ja
quasi Regierungsmitglied und aus der
Region heraus Opposition zu betreiben
das ist schon ein echter Spagat gewesen
also insofern ich schaue optimistisch
nach vorne wir werden uns neu aufstellen
als CDU Niedersachsen und bekanntlich
ist die nächste Wahl dann ja gar nicht
so weit entfernt danke Bernd Althusmann
ja den Platz an der Seite der SPD wollen
jetzt die Grünen einnehmen kräftige
Zugewinne für die Grünen
Julia Willi Hamburg ist die
Spitzenkandidatin sie haben ihre
Präferenz für ein rot-grünes Bündnis
schon im Wahlkampf wirklich nicht
versteckt melden Sie heute Abend noch
ihren Anspruch an oder schon ihren
Anspruch an auf ein Wirtschafts- und
klimaministerium bei Herrn Wald nein wir
warten jetzt erstmal die Wahlen ab aber
sichtbar ist gerade nach den derzeitigen
Erkenntnissen dass die Wählerinnen und
Wähler sich für eine rot-grüne Regierung
in diesem Land entschieden haben dass
wir diese dann auch hoffentlich bilden
können und damit Bund und Land Hand in
Hand die Menschen gut durch diesen
Winter und durch die Krise führen werden
und ich freue mich über unser historisch
bestes Wahlergebnis und über diesen
Rückenwind viele Leute an den Ständen
haben mir gesagt Sie wollen dass die
Grünen mit regieren wir hoffen dass wir
das dann jetzt auch einlösen können und
die nächsten fünf Jahre Niedersachsen
dann zukunftsfähig aufstellen vielen
Dank Frau Hamburg die grüne
Spitzenkandidat hinzugewinne auch für
die AFD während die FDP hier ein sehr
bitteren Abend erlebt Reaktionen von
beiden Spitzenkandidaten hat mein
Kollege Peter Kunz im Landtag
eingefangen
Stefan marzischewski von der AFD 12
Prozent das Wahlergebnis fast verdoppelt
mit welcher konstruktiven Politik wollen
sie dem Wähler des Vertrauen jetzt
belohnen konstruktiv das was ich gesagt
habe Politik für die Bürger vor Ort
machen zum Beispiel die Tafeln vor die
Tafeln vor Ort finanziell unterstützen
unser Wahlversprechen möglichst auch
umsetzen das heißt die
Straßenausbaubeiträge abschaffen und für
bessere Schulen sorgen und für mehr
Sicherheit im Land Niedersachsen also
hier ganz ganz explizit was für das Land
Niedersachsen tun
Stefan Birkner eine Zitterpartie für die
FDP was heißt das für sie was heißt das
für Herrn Lindner in Berlin wenn Sie
hier Niedersachsen rausfallen würden net
ich gehe davon aus dass wir demnächst
niedersächsischen Landtag angehören
werden und darauf konzentrieren wir uns
und das heißt dann zunächst einmal dass
wir alle Voraussicht nach in der
Opposition unserer Arbeit fortsetzen
werden so wie wir das in den letzten
Jahren auch getan haben als engagierte
politische Kraft
ja letzte Frage wie immer an den Wahl
Gewinner und Ministerpräsidenten Stefan
weil im Bund liegt die SPD bei 17 18
Prozent sie sind der Mann für 33 müssen
sie jetzt auch mehr Verantwortung auf
Bundesebene übernehmen werden sie ja
weil jetzt sowas wieder reservekanzler
nein ganz bestimmt nicht ich habe
eigentlich auch unter schon ganz anderen
Bedingungen immer darauf hingewiesen
dass mein Platz in Hannover ist und es
hat noch wenige Abende gegeben wo ich
das so direkt gefühlt habe wie diesen
aber ich werde natürlich auch gerne
weiter mein Teil dazu beitragen dass die
SPD nicht mehr in Niedersachsen
erfolgreich ist sondern bundesweit und
darauf können sich alle verlassen ich
stehe für ein sehr pragmatischen auch
für ein hoffentlich bürgernahen
politischen Kurs und ich bin ganz sicher
auf diese Art und Weise können wir
überall auch Punkten gerade auch in
schwierigen Situation
herzlichen Dank Herr weil herzlichen
Dank an alle Spitzenkandidaten das ist
der Wahlabend in Niedersachsen zurück
nach Mainz ins Studio zu Barbara Hellweg
Dankeschön nach Hannover für den Moment
danke Bettina welche Signal geht von
Niedersachsen nach Berlin aus vielen
galt diese Wahl als Stimmungstest für
die Ampelkoalition besonders die FDP hat
heute